yeah welcome to this video playing do
not hot chick whoops what the hell but
what the heck happened here
wow I had some really weird stuff
happening yet with the display not sure
what it was alright so let's see what
happens the caro-kann I lost about 20
seconds due to this technical issue okay
we got the pun off with 94 this funny
line and his seems to be quite quite
irritated ok d5 now is the right one and
the Queen D for the critical try 24
Queen B 6 this is them the main move or
the main line of this it's a fairly
unexplored continuation
a half you should 22mm now didn't I
didn't get this morn yet let's see okay
and I can take look be one Queen a to
make sure this is good
look slightly risky so there's some
better idea okay is threatening bishops
III covering up everything so I probably
need to take it's not a matter of time
book be one okay but this wasn't a
mandatory move of course the g6 to
prepare Bishop f5 looks looks like the
way to go this also irritate slide a bit
i'm getting a tempo and it's not so
clear how he should develop now I didn't
want to take a to fall too far behind in
development with Bishop f5 and Bishop g7
I can develop rather quickly this is
ambitious very ambitious move yeah I
guess
hmm and yet another temple with bishop
with them energy form or is there
something better even
yeah it shouldn't be too bad
it's not very well developed really okay
I can take and play 93 which isn't bad
really or is this something better queen
bee 60 probably plays c5 and this
doesn't make much sense yeah I can just
I can just play that this is perfectly
alright gain the bishop pair at least oh
and i didn't have rook c8 this is this
is quite nice folks yet how does she
protects you for I guess you had this
move and now rook c8 just attacking c4 I
don't really see how he defends it and
not sure this looks so quite nice yeah
he just gives it up
if he takes now that's III and f4 hey
and yeah he doesn't have yeah he just
doesn't he doesn't have a great rookie
move this is the move this is one of the
moves that don't look too great okay
giving you the check now I guess should
be irritating for wide diets let's keep
it simple try to win d 5 as well not
sure how I should protect it can take d6
play Bishop c4 but this looks like yeah
you cannot this is this is just not
playable yeah you can do it but it's
just terrible rookie one here
yeah he won this is this assume
something to look at I don't really want
to take giving getting two opposite
colored bishops
and let's play this first
we are still rookie one a thought Bishop
f5 just preserving the bishop no it
doesn't play it wow
okay i want to temper on the pawn to
play books eh
this bishop on not h6 is really bad I
need to reroute this piece yeah just
treat not just drop back Bishop is 78 b6
something like that
yeah came the bishop won't go to be six
mm-hmm that's not not the end of the
world
hmm
yeah he got somewhat to a demon I
probably made some mistake here
yeah I still don't see anything great
for him but it looks like oh this is
very forthcoming getting rid of rook
yeah it's much easier for me now to to
make make some progress with roofs off
if I know I'm just not quite sure but
not quite sure this was good but i'm i'm
on 30 seconds so i cannot spend spend
ages night 28
want I want to get this time warning
want to get it to see five
a former saying
check-check
check
check
check-check
me wow this was close time wise who had
it worked out at the end I couldn't
really do do any comments any more
needed to need to play quickly yeah I'm
not sure about around here I think black
has quite good winning chances with the
rocks off it just helps me to to not
worry about any rook penetrating here
that can I can make some progress with
at 5i with the computer makes an
interesting suggestion here actually it
wants to play a fire it's quite
interesting the point is if I keep it
closed then it's very difficult to get
gag get some progress go near this
Bishop on your 7s re bed now and taking
them isn't too attractive as well yeah
but ok this is this I can try can can
always use the two against one him yep
ok I thought he should should keep the
rocks on not that this ruckus is so
great but I cannot penetrate and he's
always has some ideas maybe to get get
on c7 if I try to remove my rook I don't
know it hard to me that the exchange
helps me they're louder quite quite a
lot of counter play around here it
really looks like white is totally
busted I here looks III for instance
strong yeah this is witness this win
sensibly actually cannot move this and
this is quite easy
yeah I'm really allowed quite quite much
play and what around here and it's
really a game that should should be over
really quickly all right i hope you
liked it thanks for watching